president joe biden talked with chinese
president xi today the white house says
biden warned him not to bail out russia
but that's basically all we know about
the call gensake said today we still
don't know where china stands listen
president biden wasn't making specific
requests of china why not and given the
stakes here because china has to make a
decision for themselves about where they
want to stand
and how they want the history books to
look at them and view their actions
and
that is the decision for president xi
and the chinese to make can you offer
any explanation for why the u.s still
has concerns after this call because
we'll continue to watch until
we see what actions they take or don't
take
nothing scares the chinese like the
history books
unbelievable
the call lasted nearly two hours and all
we got from it was joe told the chinese
there would be consequences if he helped
putin
but nobody knows what those consequences
are because biden didn't get into
specifics
bottom line china knows they messed up
putin can't win this war in russia's
toast
just last month they were bragging about
their limitless friendship china even
took the intel we showed him about the
russian buildup and just shared it with
the kremlin
and they asked putin to invade after the
olympics because you know they didn't
want their buddies war distracting from
the games
but the war didn't go as planned the
russian army got stuck in the mud and
their leader is now a terrorist with an
economy that can barely breathe
china hitched their wagon to a war
criminal and has a tough decision to
make if it wants to trade in dollars and
euros
the whole world is fracturing right now
so what's next
here now brigadier general peter zwack
and the marathon initiative co-founder
eldridge
colby all right eldridge so what do you
think went down on this call was joe
tough enough
well i i doubt it i seems like nothing
much really changed i mean jen saki was
pretty forthright that he didn't demand
anything uh specifically so i mean i
think the upshot of what's happening is
what you said at the end there jesse
which is that the world is probably
fracturing and there there definitely
are big downsides i'm sure the chinese
are livid at the russians more for
screwing up the invasion than for any
moral abominations that they've
certainly uh committed but look the
there is upside for the chinese here
this makes the russians
a lot more pliable for them they have a
lot less leverage and i think we're
seeing the beginnings of the formation
of a chinese-led block i don't think the
chinese are ready to come out of the
gate yet but you see you know the saudis
trading in yuan uh you see the indians
continue uh buying russian oil uh the
chinese have made it i think pretty
clear that they're going to continue to
support the russians they may you know
not want to take political heat for it
but i think in practice both on the on
the economic sanctions of asian side but
even potentially in militarily relevant
equipment or resources they seem to be
sticking with their with their with
their man there
in general how does joe punish the
chinese and make it clear they better
not deal with the russians anymore than
they already are
i think that um i think that the actions
taken i don't know what was exactly in
the conversation
uh were prudent the message was sent
the specifics of whatever reaction if
the chinese were to be more robust in
their support including military no
don't need to be out there
another point uh yes it does look like
the world is in many ways
fracturing but i will say that this
russian
aggression this invasion
and all that has come with it and china
needs to be careful here has done more
to pull together the west and the
like-minded nations of the world of
anything i can think of uh since uh
since uh
you know since uh a generation ago so so
the chinese are on notice the russians
are in deep trouble um the chinese have
hitched their wagon uh but they're also
worried about getting dragged into some
this is bad for the chinese brand yeah
and they are all intermingled so a lot
going on i believe we're on the i
believe the message sent was was
appropriate i hope so and eldridge you
agree
nato is pretty strong
america is paying attention to russia
and china pretty carefully and our
pacific partners are pretty fired up the
south koreans the japanese and the
australians have you know we've
encircled the chinese so um you know i
don't think china is very happy with
this russian invasion wouldn't you agree
there
well i think they're unhappy that it's
not gone well i i'd be a little more
pessimistic about how things stand i
think we have a long long way to go uh
with our you know coalition in asia uh
you know the japanese still aren't
spending enough on defense the south
koreans have been out of the game for a
few years hopefully the new government
will be better the australians are
leading the way but the taiwanese
haven't been doing enough for their
defense and look the chinese they're
increasing their defense spending by
seven percent again uh this year they
they're leading the field i mean whether
we like it or not in areas like
artificial intelligence
so you know i agree with peter europe
has really stepped up i wish it hadn't
taken an invasion for this to happen but
the germans the poles the romanians etc
but a lot of that is is let's be frank
as cluster in the european world a lot a
lot of countries in the developing world
are taking a different position so i
think this is just the beginning
unfortunately or you know if you will
the beginning of the end of this the end
of the beginning of this competition but
the chinese aren't going anywhere and
and we really need to focus on them we
need to deal with the russians and help
the ukrainians fight them strengthen
nato build on what's happening uh but
but not take our eye off the ball uh
fundamentally which is which is uh you
know
the main issue is is really china and it
will be for for a long long time all
right peter real quick because we got to
pay some bills does china move on taiwan
because of this or not
i think i think that right now the way
one strategic geostrategic issue if
russia totters or fails then russia
china has lost if you will its major
geostrategic partner as far as how they
see the world view while they have
completely different things i think they
make the move on on taiwan i think that
they're exposed everything about their
economy um is vulnerable i think it
would be catastrophic for them
and but saying that and their own
population will be watching no this is
incredibly complex and incredibly
dangerous period for all of us all right
sure is all right gentlemen thank you
guys so much for joining primetime have
a great weekend
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else